[Music]
I've made a severe and continuous lapse
of my judgment and I don't expect to be
forgiven I'm simply here to apologize
YouTube star Logan Paul is apologizing
after sharing a video from the Japanese
suicide forest so we came across that
day in the woods was obviously unplanned
and the reactions you saw on tape were
raw they were unfiltered none of us knew
how to react right a few I should have
never posted the video the since deleted
vlog featured a dead body
Logan claimed he posted the graphic
footage to raise awareness for suicide
prevention I want to apologize to the
Internet one of apologize to anyone
who's seen the video I want to apologize
to anyone who has been affected or
touched by mental illness or depression
or suicide but most importantly I want
to apologize to the victim and his
family celebs like Aaron Paul sophie
Turner and Rebecca Black expressed their
outrage on Twitter and some people even
called on YouTube to ban the 22 year old
from creating more content my fans who
are defending my actions please don't
they do not deserve to be defended
[Music]
you